[Music]
in childhood crib news how MTV crude and
the special submitted by that [ __ ]
hurted gosh had the hardest the home
President Trump was raised in is now
available for rent on Airbnb one has
craze is it the almond know was really
cold by miss the trucks austra became a
millionaire maybe he wasn't once he was
right I was wrong okay for money he came
from money dad owned a ton of like real
estate and hotels and stuff he grew into
that okay you're like I'm trying to
understand why he's such a peasant
because what like I remember that he
must be a selling that right yeah right
but the reason why he's so gaudy and
like new money mentality I think his dad
is a self-made guy I don't know if he
has no like old money type of vibe yeah
so president Trump's childhood home is
now on Airbnb is it ballin uh it's a
humble really high bedroom traditional
home probably three and a half bathroom
how many square feet though it doesn't
family square feet but 14 beds and two
sofa beds okay 14 beds okay do you have
a lot of siblings I'm not sure where is
this what so this is a New York and in
Queens looking queen yeah so this is oh
no very regular why is he with that
PhotoShelter a homeowner actually has
like a cutout of that is creepy
there's also like art of him everywhere
why why the home looks like do five
bedrooms that should look like you only
got from a genera be and being your
house and just putting a cutout of
yourself like I can and so you som this
is very like anything that a door go
back where oh it does look like a door
and then right here in this room there's
this frame here that says it's good
enough for trumpets good enough for me I
grab those eyes up [ __ ] like Trump
favorite quotes every root of all the
brains in this bedroom President Donald
J Trump was likely conceived by his
parents Fred and Mary Trump the world
has never been the same after that I
think I like my job for my own home
would day yeah I like there's some like
Trump art like Andy Warhol styles in
this condition alas oh yeah they're
saying that you can rent it out for
seven hundred and twenty five dollars a
night
what it doesn't look too far as I
thought of a five-bedroom in New York I
mean that sounds reasonable but I'm kind
of really cuz it says it's only up to
two guess it was two guests but it
sleeps 2016 bed maybe they don't want a
party there maybe that and then they're
weird yeah and then the post also
mentions that whoever owns this home
they have a private apartment within the
residence so they will be able to so
it's not like I guess the entire house
oh that's one thing when I'm always
getting an Airbnb [ __ ] thing I always
ask is anyone to send a property with me
because they never did like a lot of
people don't disclose that I don't want
to be [ __ ] surprised you have to
click entire plate no this one's not
entire home but then if you're
reasonable you have to read it girl
it says that they see their whoa hey
dude I didn't know that I should start
reading that I don't want to live with
people and read it anymore so I'm like
I'm just going to ask you what the [ __ ]
I wanted I just in case come on of your
mouth yeah but once this was posted the
media went crazy with it with headlines
like you can now [ __ ] Trump childhood
home I need is fought well this one that
a gizmo
thanks to Airbnb you can [ __ ] come
childhood home dirty ass gizmo can I air
B&B George Washington's child at home
recently I asked you guys like who who
would whose home or what like home in
the movies like Beyonce Rihanna
I didn't oh I wanna air B&B Mariah
Carey's home she lives in the castle way
but I guess it's the childhood home I
want to do the night at home I want to
do the parent home yeah I don't care
about the childhood Hall of yeah for
sure or even like uh I don't know what
like your guys like the home alone house
oh that would be quarter like full house
the cool house house yeah I want to do
the pee-wee Herman house Oh
Hutten masturbating the movie theaters
yeah my new incoming wasn't let him tell
true I been with child pornography you
have a movie theater with child
pornography oh he was just jacking off
at a porno theater oh oh an authorial
didn't even know that existed porno
theaters is crazy
they exist on my dad first can America
real be yeah my dad said he paid the
hooker and then he went to a theater
could he thought that sort of miracle is
all about being deaf much better yeah
he's just business back in when sunset
there's just Street walkers so he wanted
to feel what a white girl [ __ ] felt
like and then he went into one of those
porno theaters and the Oakland American
experience
oh I'm officially in America how does it
build on all the rumors about that so he
uh he did a three things he banged a
white girl and then he went into a porno
theater and then he bought a Buick
because viewers root analyst at that
time they were the baton of your dream
yeah
no automobile color supreme recess about
oldsmobile cutlass supreme
Wow and if I like Americans I think for
me the one room that I would want to
like actually be real life would be the
room that Hey Arnold had oh my god that
is Amit is such a good world skylights
and yeah you know they're coming out
with a movie stop this yet it's finally
going to tell you about Arnold's parents
I'm so Emily yeah whoo Hey Arnold
it's a cartoon series on you know who
hate art at all it's a cartoon series
that was on Nickelodeon and it came out
around the Metro if you want down you
don't know you'll love hey I don't even
have Nickelodeon I didn't stick with it
but I watched a few oh one of the best
series
bestir skewed like hit Arnold with my
version with his little hair just tiny
little hat you do know them know what
room with Rugrats
this was a one you regret I here with
Rutgers - you saw the rerun well then
brother the heels are so different this
is just a cartoon different yeah yeah
yeah well it's live action I don't know
it could be the ad I sure was Doug I
gotta school Doug is call rainy night
Stimpy was really weird
that was my fave no I couldn't get into
a curse - Cowardly Dog
that was my [ __ ] I was gonna run after
but it's not really yellow no I watched
courage no yeah well I watched it too
but it was like more than your cartoons
they were going in that same era of what
we're talking about yeah CatDog CatDog
oh okay that was modern life yeah
and what was it Rocko's Modern Life it
was that doggy
oh I never was trailing it know your
than a dog he was like Kendra or
something oh he wasn't at all not as a
lobby that one oh I thought he was a dog
and well maybe my child memory is just
things it's a dog because it didn't know
what a kangaroo was ha ha ha that makes
lunch oh yeah I think for me I don't
know I just want to visit all like a set
of Game of Thrones something like
majestic I want to air BB a castle like
wonderful Winterfell 500 miles yeah
how'd it go we gotta take a [ __ ] on the
toilet he King Lou the 14 the Palace of
Versailles I'd air B&B that [ __ ] oh yeah
the sanitary thing you know walking
through it uh pleasing parents with me
this is actually someone home at one
point like damn a true you know
everyone's home everyone is it looks
funny though
today contemporary homes are better
bedrooms than back then and his bed was
like a [ __ ] full-size bed yeah tiny I
did the girls do the beds were like
smaller than twin size did you see his
mistress passageways no we did get to
see that into the bedrooms
no we they closed off like the bottom
floor stuff hmm cuz in the bedrooms like
you could see like a slight cut out and
then so that oh I saw the cut out doors
yeah cut out doors those are for a
secret passageway to all his mistresses
I keep trying to get to the garden wall
I breathe through all of that I'm still
bummed out dad
I don't know where else you guys ever
wanted is it I liked Hey Arnold that was
like the best like a real life one okay
really I want to see real-life modern
celebrity homes yeah I want to Airbnb
celebrities everyone paid up to hang out
with yeah you could own them or like
this day yeah what if you're on that on
that list I'm not a celebrity
no cuz you are to some people you could
do that right now for the low price of
ten thousand dollars then you come see
me and we can hang out yeah I'm cheap
oh I know which house the mr. and mrs.
Smith house where the kitchen has all
the guns and stuff but you open the oven
and it's a bunch of like submachine guns
yes I'll be tight I want to see
everything the house from
blank check I would want to say the
stepbrothers house oh that would be a
good imaginal touch my drums yeah it
would have to have all the same stuff
yeah really have you guys ever air B&B
like like a place that you want to go to
like for example I did this for Hawaii
right when I was looking for homes
I just put no limit for the money I put
as high as possible and there's actually
a home call like the Obama is State or
something like Wow I don't know if I
have anything to do with Obama's home or
anything like that but it's like a
Hawaiian palace how much is it it was
like 30 grand a night 30 grand I was
like a thousand really dope no there's
homes out there that are like $20,000 a
night or whatever you know those are for
the like the Kardashians Georgia didn't
[ __ ] anything on time let me just go on
Airbnb yeah it's crazy I was looking up
random homes and there's one in the
Hollywood Hills it has 30 rooms and so
like the back of the house there's like
this entire strip that's a cliff and
then there's a pool and then there's
this glass fence that goes around so no
one could fall off the cliff and you get
to look at all of downtown LA ah 7dg is
a night
night imagine having out of my little of
hall imagine throwing away that kind of
money though because I'm just like that
makes me want to buy a big around house
and just rent it and make your money
back so you just feel like the world
could be such a better place if people
weren't setting seventy thousand dollars
a night on Airbnb that's insane yeah
that's insane
rolling laughing girl I chose it that's
more than like some people's annual
salaries I'm just like look at you get a
lot of yo name dr. Gavin DG's eliminate
one of the Knights donate it to a woman
battered shelters I'm just saying
they're better this week to do with 70
Jason women I know you greedy
[ __ ] give it to me or me yeah I
need charity too we can also clip that
70 yeah and we can make a paste out of
it but that Trump house definitely seems
like it was it's there like that 725
it's not worth that I would not name and
it's definitely they're making it like a
museum yeah which is weird for a band
alyssum because like if you like really
hate Trump you could just like rent it
out and then like do the vandalism yeah
Shawn to the on it though yeah he has no
association with it it's just hurting
random innocent people again they even
have it on the listing - look we're not
associated at all hey guys I hope you
enjoyed that episode of just kidding
news and if there's a story that you
guys want us to talk about go ahead down
into our description box below and
there's a link there where you can
submit articles for the next video click
right up here
[Music]